bullet pass Bradley No and finally the
pelicans cure rebound up a heads I gives
it up for Howard tough pass good defense
there by Redick
giving up a lot of size finishes with
this strong hand Bop is when you get up
but I'm just letting you know that quick
second jump because of that early
turnover for heating of no defensive
balance by New Orleans to get back but
here pelicans and a big win on Friday
the Warriors high on Antoine it goes
strong and he'll go to the line third
meeting of the year between the Lakers
and the pelicans pelicans are right now
10th in the West
climbing fast and green gets us started
tonight got a hand on it now Caruso runs
a break
[Applause]
he up there again his ball cannot
convert it's trying to take it inside
and they are being met heavily James
about an 11 old LeBron run here for Los
Angeles appreciate frank vogel Chris
Hayes opening up this fourth quarter the
Lakers in the lead we saw on the dish
from LeBron James occupies the
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
looking to push tempo here the pelicans
number five in the NBA in fast-break
points
favors no but Silas there with the stick
back slam screen by Williamson look into
roll that green recovered now the LOB
from Lanza but what play by suck items
are on pace the pelicans are on pace for
80 points in the paint
so the initial matchup and the health of
Francis talking about bring it there Tom
the pelicans up one they go to Williams
and facing up and driving make that a
tougher shot on Brandon Ingram you
thought he got separation that's
multiple effort by coos bonds all balls
perfected that with Williamson does a
teammate texting he looked at LeBron and
pointed in his chest like my fault
[Applause]
Williamson tonight for James holiday to
a budding Williamson and science goes up
straw the chest of Dwight Howard that's
a guy 611 a future Hall of Famer who has
blocked see it's a little bit here at
the rim and see you meet you Vail
[Applause]
rejected by McGee teams goes behind the
back and then reverse layup is good
James botting Josh Hart too powerful
forum Leblon up and under good and one
you might anticipate the Lakers without
Anthony Davis in the help position would
give up more paint points tonight
obviously James going it's ion and
LeBron wins that one but let's just
watch LeBron I mean you know you know in
Gladiator where that guy says not yet
he'll try a three no good
rebounded by James looking to run here
LeBron now past the cooze ball for two
tremendous catch
eleven and a quarter Wow James for about
28 feet
I think the Zion dunk may be trigger
that shot by James from this in a
spotlight in making the most of it which
then led to this that was past 30 here's
James guarded by part LeBron 10 of 16
shooting 11 assists so far team blows
past Hart and James it 13 triple doubles
now for LeBron James
tying luca dont't for the NBA lady and
going up against Williams and fires
that's a pray over Zion who can only
smile he's half his age LeBron's got a
son that's only four years younger than
Zion and it's if science and I'm kind of
enjoying this toe-to-toe affair LeBron
James little jab step back into a rhythm
free money
the Lakers fan